міжнародному суді він у газі раз купа
все розліт покличу україни протарасі та
Мета процес він з найважливіших для суду
за астані рук і причина поклику задуху
детальному позу вина 45 store ніг та діти
про доручення росію 2 конвенції оон про
днів і пробувати намистин назвою туризму
кривду ну а чого москву петр їм тіла
збійних групу донецьку це луганську
областях інше для ліквідації всіх форм
расової дискримінації та дайте про горішки
кримських татар то за оборону меджлісу
україна вимагаючи по карате росію з і
збут або так має 17 обстріли
мирного населення на донбасі доводь
для суду доведено дуб за вислугу їжа
з відео он-бі міжнародні
групи з розслідування збут його на
донеччині малайзійського боїнгу а також
супутникові знімки на те процедура суду
слухання проходять і каламутно поетапно
купону робити і сер їжу виступаючи україна
у віктора як р-рос залом за
прогнозам експертів суд може рвати і
кейко rock you
у чеканя вигляд суду експерти не покладаючи
на процес великих знайди по польщі суд
можемо і вирішить ще тебе праворуч на його
компоту анти подругою видно з процедуру
і суду пишною зсунуті сяду його в
бік мати провести серйозно непрямого
ний діалог сюди але масу б 2 країни
вийдуть вже давно а відліку криму москва
виду вести переговори сама через
навик вона і не розуму про переговори
міжнародні суди 2011 уроки 7 фу
поклич грузії протарасі та різанини позички
міжнародний суд оон
часто плутають міжнародним кримінальним
судом астані я тут не переслідую
адже вусик праве далеких за ану колір
твоєї не закруту закрут про ту люди
на steam а міжнародного суду оон
розлита супер ich komme ich державам
ще пов'язані з порушенням міжнародних
догляд і зуба в'язати обидва ван і катю їх
толмача нею в даному аранті притягує
па дальності високого суду актив
засіки президента Росії
суд не можемо дакота